[Música]
y llegó el momento de revista de prensa
en directo américa de france24 rosa
pérez masdéu conmigo en el estudio rosa
ya estamos a miércoles el séptimo día de
esta invasión de rusia a ucrania y
abrimos por supuesto con un tema
publicado esta mañana por la prensa
ucraniana los planes del presidente ruso
vladimir putin para restituir en el
poder al que fuera el presidente
ucraniano yanukóvich algo que pareciera
en estos días no estar tan descabellado
rosa buenos días raúl efectivamente como
hemos venido comentando hay muchísimas
informaciones que circulan a día de hoy
y muchas difíciles de comprobar y de
contrastar recalcamos que esta
información está publicada en un medio
ucraniano que se llama ukrainska pravda
y de la que se ha hecho eco también el
kif independent nosotros la citamos pero
recordamos insistimos que no la podemos
contrastar pero bien esta información
teóricamente
estuvo proporcionada por la inteligencia
ucraniana que asegura que en minsk está
teniendo lugar la preparación de una
operación entre el kremlin y el que
fuera el presidente de ucrania víctor
yanukóvich que recordemos huyó del país
tras la explosión de las protestas
conocidas como el euro maidán de hecho
este medio dice que es el kremlin
estaría preparando una operación con el
fugitivo ex presidente y dicen la
información obtenida indica que el
kremlin podría estar preparando una
operación de información o una acción
para que el ex presidente yanúkovich
regrese a ucrania o para publicar un
comunicado en su nombre dirigido al
pueblo ucraniano a corto plazo estos son
todos los detalles que nos ofrece este
medio por el momento sin duda iremos
ampliando o desmintiendo esta
información a lo largo de los días claro
que sí rosa y también en esta sección
revista de prensa vamos ahora con un
tema que nos llega directamente desde el
otro lado de moscú hablamos de la
editorial del medio ruso 'novaya gazeta'
trabajar en tiempos de guerra rosa así
es este medio independiente de rusia
pone a sus lectores la siguiente
situación dice que tanto la fiscalía
como el regulador de los medios de
comunicación les está imponiendo algo
que ya hemos comentado en esta sección a
de forma reiterada y es que eliminen las
referencias a la guerra oa la invasión a
de ucrania y que se refieran a ello como
una operación especial como hemos venido
comentando ante este panorama este medio
de comunicación plantea a sus lectores
que prefieren si se que sigan informando
bajo las limitaciones de la censura
militar o que suspendan la actividad en
la redacción mientras dure esta
operación especial y así ya se refieren
en este texto y ante pues este
planteamiento ante esta encuesta cuatro
mil cuatrocientos sesenta personas
electoras de este periódico votaron y un
93,9 por ciento de ellas votaron a favor
de que continúe pues esta labor
periodística
aún así sea pues bajo esta censura de
las autoridades de moscú y en los
comentarios leemos pues muchos ánimos no
a la redacción de este medio ruso ante
la situación qué
continuamos con una prensa moscovita
vamos a ver en el moscú está en un
artículo el fallo estratégico de putin y
el riesgo de una escalada rosa así es es
un análisis muy interesante de nivel
good davis dice que esta invasión ante
ucrania se revela como un error
estratégico y que se basó en delirios de
vladimir putin respecto a ucrania
occidente y rusia dice por un lado
vladimir putin subestimó la voluntad y
la capacidad de resistencia del pueblo
ucraniano y que de hecho con esta
invasión los está cuestionando todavía
más y reforzando todavía más su
identidad nacional subestimó también la
cohesión política de occidente y también
por las sanciones que están imponiendo
pues todo oxidante de forma unánime ya
la que se están sumando también medidas
por parte de las grandes corporaciones
privadas también subestimó la oposición
interna e incluso la inquietud de las
propias élites rusas dice aquí vladimir
putin tiene dos opciones por una es
aumentar la violencia de esta guerra
pero aún así tendría un problema de
legitimidad
fuera pues el gobierno que acabará
imponiendo en kiev y por otro lado
firmar la paz pero dice esto sería una
humillación que putin sólo aceptaría así
peligrar a su propio régimen nos fijamos
ahora en él le monde de francia que
trata de fijarnos en el trato mediático
que le dé esta guerra y su impacto en
medio oriente rosa así es porque la
asociación de periodistas árabes y de
medio oriente denuncia una cobertura
racista por parte de distintos en medios
de comunicación y es que de hecho pues
medios como la cbs o the telegraph han
hecho referencia a lo que sucede en
ucrania diciendo que era inesperado en
un lugar civilizado o no en que son tan
parecidos a los europeos que tienen
netflix o que tienen instagram y
básicamente los periodistas árabes y de
medio oriente critican lo que es la euro
en la cobertura racista como decíamos
por esta mentalidad omnipresente en el
periodismo occidental que normaliza la
tragedia en religiones como medio
oriente áfrica sudeste asiático y
américa latina' rosa gracias entonces
por toda la por toda la información de
la revista de prensa el día de hoy
mañana con más pasamos ahora a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado del día